How's it going bros? This is PewDiePie!
I am in New York, for the YouTube Summit.
If you don't know what that is...
I don't know either.
I don't know why I'm here. But, all I know... it should be pretty exciting.
I'm gonna meet up with a lot of cool people today.
It's 7:00 am, so I'm gonna go to the gym for an hour to waste some time.
And... I'm bringing you bros along.
It should be a fun day.
Alright, so these are all goody bags for other YouTubers.
So, the whole hotel is rented out just for YouTubers.
Thanks. Appreciate it.
Rule #1 of exercise.
It only counts if you share it on the internet.
I didn't realize they had pounds in America.
I was like, "Jesus Christ, I'm so fucking strong."
It's pretty pathetic.
Anyway, I feel good.
So... YouTube got me a gift.
A little...
Oh, sorry!
What have we got here?
Unboxing with PewDiePie!
"Welcome to New York City... We're pumped to have you here..."
"This week is going to be action-packed, check out the attached schedule..."
Cool.
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOH.
Ultra moisturizing.
I hate moisture. *throws the lotion*
Adult coloring book!
I HATE. (breathing)
I hate coloring books for adults!
YouTube, what the hell, man?
You said you would get me Swedish licorice. I'm so disappointed.
I get this garbage!
*giggles*
I'm sorry, thank you very much.
I really appreciate it.
*kiss*
Thank you.
Uhhh
This has been Unboxing with PewDiePie.
I hope you enjoyed.
Now I'm gonna unbox myself.
If you know what I mean.
OH! someone is at the door, I wonder who it could be- *Jack fondles himself*
*they laugh*
Hoes!
YAY!
Guten tag (Hello) my friend.
Yes.
This is it, guys.
It's happening.
*whisper* Oh my God.
Uhh, Jack, would you like to smash me?
I just wanna- we're gonna smash.
Pewds: "Smash me up, bro.   Jack: "We're gonna smash his pillow."
Pewds: "NO, stop."  Jack: "Oh yeah! YEAH!" *smashing sounds*
Pewds: "Stop!"
Jack: "YEAH! YEAH! SMASH!"
It's time to confess my YouTube sins.
Dashie: "I want to be that guy"
Mark: "No, get out."
Pewds: "What are you doing?"
Get away!
No.
Mark: "Shh"
Jack: "Thank you"
Mr. Booth: "My name is Mr. Booth."
"What is your name?"
Jack: "Mister Slooth."
Mark: "Shut the fuck up."
Pewds: "Jack, that's just... no."
Mr. Booth: "Which one of you is PewDiePie?"
Me
That guy
This one.
Mr. Booth: "Would you rather wear pants that make a horse sound everyday..."
"...Or no pants at all?"
All: "No pants at all!"
Pewds: "Come on."
Mr Booth: "The two of you do your best impression of PewDiePie on a rollercoaster stuck upside down."
*screaming* woohwoohwooh
Top a da morning to ya, laddies!!!
Aaaaaaaaa.....
Mark: "Oh, fuck off, that doesn't feel right."
*giggles*
*laughing out loud*
Ha ha!
What the fuck?
Oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh shit, oh my God.
WOOOOOH.
So, we were asked to make a taco, but we made this.
This is our creation.
Is this not beautiful?
The tounge made it out is the best part, that was an accident!
We need a name!
Pewds: "Uhh..."
Pewds: "What's the name?"
Pewds: "If you put a name in the comments, you could win this watermelon."
Comment right now! *might I suggest... PewDieMelon?*
The winner will get a gift signed!
And a stab by the Pewds himself!
Pewds: "Don't tell what I'm gonna do!" *PewDieMelon...*
I will do it, I will definitely. *PewDieMelon!*
come on. come on.
tastiest tacos.
*they don't win*
That's the worst competition... Fuck them.
I hate pugs.
Oh wait, no... I... I...
Jack's stupid team won.
Look at that fucking asshole. *I like how he zooms in on MatPat instead*
I hate him.
What a fucking dickhead.
Put like a fucking deodorant.
*laughing*
Mark: "Congratulations."
Pewds: "Oh, thank you!" Mark: "You have the best taco."
Pewds: "Thank you."
No one wants the trophy?
Is that it?
Alright, cool, thank you.
Appreciate it.
All right. Well, clearly I won.
Pewds: "Hey, at least I don't have a cooking channel."
Pewds: "At least I don't have a fucking cooking channel."
Harley: "I could kill this guy right now
so fast!"
Pewds: Do it, do it mothafucker!
Harley: "Okay, first of all, I know you guys don't doubt for a second
that I could beat them both up at the same time, right now."
Pewds: Oh you wanna put that to the test?"
*giggles*
Yeah!
Let's test it!
Pewds: "Meet me outside, bitch!"
Mark: "All of us could pound on the groin, just as fast as we can (?)."
Mark: "And that's how we'll win."
Harley: "Yeah, pounding on the groin is just going to make me cum."
"Can you say that on your video?"
"Where's your camera? I'm sorry."
Pewds: "What do you think I do?"
Pewds: "They found us..."
"...they know who we are..."
All right, I haven't vlogged anything. I'm sorry.
We're heading to the party.
Now iht- now it's happening.
We're going in the bus.
Just like the good ol' days.
Yes, should I close this door?
I'll close this door.
It closes automatically.
I am so sorry.
*singing* Yeah!
I NEED A MAN. ♪
*facepalm*
Hey, bros.
My voice is really dead, last night was really fun.
Today I have an interview with Time magazine.
Umm, It's really cool, I want to show you.
Alright, so, Time's "100 Most Influential People."
I am the only one from Sweden.
Ayyy!
And there I am!
Felix Kjellberg, a.k.a PewDiePie.
And it's written by Trey Parker (the South Park guy?)!
I don't know how this happened,
but,
when I saw it,
I was just so happy.
It's such an honor,
um,
especially that Trey wrote it.
That really means a lot, I think it was really cool.
It's gonna be a hard one to beat.
Anyway, now we're doing an interview for it.
Um, hopefully they're not recording my voice 'cause,
Jesus, I hear how bad it sounds
Um, I gotta pack super fast.
Just wanna say, um, I met a lot of really cool YouTubers.
At the Summit, everyone was so nice, and so fun to hang out with.
I had a blast.
Thanks to everyone I met here in New York.
I love you. You are awesome.
Thanks to you bros for watching this vlog! If you enjoyed...
Leave a like, I appreciate yah. *you say "appreciate" a lot in this*